name's sal khan i'm the founder and
faculty of the khan academy and it's
it's most known for a library of of uh
2000 plus videos on everything from
basic edition all the way up to calculus
and biology and chemistry but what we're
really trying to do is build a free
not-for-profit virtual school that
anybody can go there's the videos but
there's also software they can start at
basic concepts and then just keep moving
up until you know they know calculus and
physics and whatever else
the details have yet to be worked out
but what we're building like you know
we're talking as a virtual school but we
actually do see it as kind of the
operating system for the school of the
future and we're starting trials already
the model we're experimenting with and
it seems to be working is
you use the self-paced software you use
the video you use the uh the technology
for every for every student to work at
their own pace so literally you have a
class of you can have 30 students or 50
students or however many students and
and they actually don't all have to be
the same age preferably they're all of
different ages all of different skill
levels and they use something like the
khan academy they'll work at their own
pace
and the teacher now doesn't have to give
lectures doesn't have to grade homework
doesn't have to do anything other than
they have a real-time dashboard we
actually have this already but they have
a real-time dashboard where they see
where every student is working at their
own pace and it just highlights the kids
that are stuck not the kids that are
behind or the kids in their head they're
just the kids that are stuck they've
already done 100 computer generated
exercises most students who've done 100
exercises have moved on the student
hasn't and the model is
as as a first point of intervention
actually the teacher even the software
can say why don't you pair up those two
students who are stuck on negative
numbers why don't you pair them up with
susie who's already gotten through that
and and have her teach them and then you
have this whole peer-to-peer when you
actually teach something you learn it
better and scales up the whole you know
it makes it a social experience but if
that doesn't work or if susie's not
available then the teacher goes there
and the teacher does a very focused
one-on-one or one-on-two intervention so
it changes the model so every minute of
a teacher's time is actually very
focused um but because it's very f you
know you don't want kids spending like
half you know the whole day on a
computer just you know clicking on
problems and
so so i'd see you spend
maybe two hours a day doing that to get
your
your core
kind of knowledge out of the way you
know you do that you're going to do well
in the sct you're going to pass the ap
test you're going to
know how to you know
grammatically write a sentence all of
the rest but what it does is freeze up
the rest of the day so you can actually
do actual creative projects i mean
there's a lot of talk about
project-based learning but very little
of it is actual real kind of liberated
creative stuff yeah yeah i mean i see
the school future big school room every
kid working at their own pace a lot of
time freed up and the teacher is now a
coach and a lot of time freed up for
kids to really be creative